so this weekend Sony's got a really big
event coming up to celebrate the 20th
anniversary of the PlayStation and show
off a lot of new stuff that's coming out
over the next year maybe two years
you're going I am going I'm not um but
it doesn't mean I get to play with this
yeah a few days before the event Sony
announced the 20th anniversary special
edition of the PlayStation 4 which we
just got in the office today yeah and uh
we all know you guys love unboxing
videos so we're going to unbox this
thing um these are very these are very
limited quantities there's about 12,300
worldwide and that means 4,100 per ter
so these are very rare so I'm going to
be very careful with this thing which is
very heavy get this little slip case off
here now delicate what makes this so
special apart from being
limited is that the
system oh wow it's beautiful oh my God I
wish you guys could smell this it's
amazing the system is colored in the
original gray as Sony puts it like the
original PlayStation um it's got a
little bit of a uh individual numbered
serial here we have number
11,259 and uh there are a lot of really
nice details on here uh there is a sort
of uh embossed pattern on this panel
that's got the PlayStation buttons and
the number 20 uh to celebrate the 20th
anniversary and uh you know I mean apart
from that this is basically your regular
old PlayStation 4 it's got 500 GB of
hard drive space does everything you'd
expect um here yes in addition to the
system this also comes
with a controller that features the same
original gray coloring as the original
PlayStation um likewise we've got the
PlayStation
camera ooh so all of these come with the
PlayStation logo in the original four
color scheme which is uh I guess nice I
don't know uh but yeah I mean so that's
kind of it but you know this is sort of
a commemorative like limited release
thing and we're going to pull out the
old PlayStation here just to give you an
idea of how these colors match
up I don't know what do you think it's a
little bit darker little biter but I
think they sort of nailed it down here
they're pretty similar and they have the
little colored logo as well exactly yeah
yeah this is heavier right heavier uh a
little bit heavier little bit a little
bit heavier a little bit
heavier um yeah so I mean that's that's
basically it you know when it comes to
uh what you're you get you get some
extra accessories if you were to buy all
this stuff at retail you would pay $20
less than what this cost this is about
$500 so if you want to get one of these
you have to be either at the PlayStation
experience event in Las Vegas this
weekend uh or if you stay tuned to the
keynote Saturday morning at 10: a.m.
that's streaming on Sony's website
they're going to tell you how you can
pre-order one but like I said these are
super limited they're going to go fast
so you probably want to be there ready
to go yeah page memorize your credit
card
number yeah uh so there you have it this
is the 20th anniversary special edition
of the PlayStation 4 coming out very
soon and uh good luck de one if you're
going to
try